how's it going bros my name pewdiepie
welcome to freddy rip
[Music]
what
it's been a month we have a lot to talk
about there's been pizza controversy i
gave away my 100 million award random
memes
let's start with uh with this one
pewdiepie's
why does this keep happening
what is wrong with my phone stop
before video begins
rich walling you should buy a rich
wallet rage wallet rich one which one
you're still using a clunky bagel clunky
wallet i'm actually really excited to be
working with rich wallet because i was
looking into their products on my own as
you guys know i am an epic minimalist at
heart so i wanted to downscale so it
makes sense to try and downscale your
giant clunky wallet to something more
simple and that's exactly what rich
wallet is i was really struck by how
tiny it is it's really easy to get the
cards out you just do that and then you
squeeze
bada bing bada boom
it fits 12 cards
but you're not gonna have 12 cards
that's just cringe i've seen people rave
about this product it seems like it's
getting a ton of great reviews honestly
i can't fault it in anything if it's
their cash at the back i picked the
carbon fiber one they have a ton of cool
designs i recommend checking out at the
website it's just very light that's why
i like the carbon fiber one like they
also sent me this one it feels really
premium the only sort of criticism i've
seen on rich wallet is that they're a
bit on the pricier side but keep in mind
that this is the kind of sturdy wallet
that they want you to keep around for a
long time it's not the kind of wallet
where you change every other year or
something like that so in the long run
it will probably save you money another
great way to get around it is the fact
that you get 10 off if you add a code
pewdiepie that's right right now they
have an offer by checking out the link
in description and using pewdiepie you
get a 10 up which i highly recommend
it's a great product i use it i really
enjoy it oh it says here it actually has
lifetime warranty well there you go each
wallet comes with a lifetime warranty so
it also has an rfid blocking which means
thieves can't uh you know digitally
steal your wallet which
yeah it's good so yeah thank you
richwallet for sponsoring this video
check out link
see you next time enjoy the video bye
pewdiepie sent me his play button as a
wedding gift what should i do with it so
yeah it is true i did send it to liz
lava and i know this will not make any
sense at all for a lot of people i feel
like 20 year old me would have been like
what the [ __ ] why would he do that
that's the dumbest [ __ ] ever it's kind
of like nerfing yourself right there's
so much importance into this one item
that to me it's just a piece of metal
but now i have to bring this piece of
metal with me wherever i go and it's
apparently i don't
how do i explain i don't like putting
value into items okay i i like putting
value into action and yeah i guess
that's it people knew what we
accomplished with this channel people
know about the hundred million thing the
award is great i i loved receiving it
and i don't want to see him ungrateful
for
getting it but at the end of the day
keeping it to me just seems like i don't
know i just don't find it that important
this is my personal philosophy and how i
view things i know a lot of people don't
share it that's fine and that's why i
thought okay why why don't i just give
it away to someone that would really
really appreciate it and i wanted to
give it away to my fans in a way and
obviously i can't give it to all my fans
so that's why i thought it made sense to
give it to lizard love to someone that
would appreciate it at least to me i
just felt like it was a thing that had
too much importance to it that i didn't
want to
it's too much i don't want it it's not
mine anymore whatever happens to it i
don't care i've given away awards or or
given away
in the past and then like end up in all
these weird [ __ ] places i'm like okay
so i i thought it made sense to give it
someone that would take care of it at
least if that's what that means i don't
know it doesn't matter nothing matters
me watching youtube or describing what
vpn is
it's funny though cause like i really
spent a lot of time describing the
details in my last promo and they were
like a lot of people signed up this time
good job i'm like oh maybe i should
explain what a vpn is in the future
instead of screaming i'll kidnap my dog
or something sweden norway finland
superior country bro finland is the
swamp land don't even why did i wear my
headphones don't even pretend finland
even is a thing stop at finland you will
never be a team family peter buys
enemies
you gotta have an enemy oh speaking of
which new enemy don't worry we're
putting our norway differences aside we
have a new enemy the new enemy is
pewdiepie highlights channel they posted
this look what they posted be on the
right side of history pewdiepie
highlights upload clip daily including
highlights on weekends pewdiepie no
upload on weekends because i get tired
are you kidding me it's up to pewdiepie
highlights bro can we get to 100k so
that they can give away the award as
well i love pewds norwegian now x fan
here i have your g fuel hostage stop
your attack on norway or this little guy
gets in okay we will not attack norway
just don't take the g fuel please i just
claimed antarctica checkmate united
nations do you think lizard lava can
trade the 100 mil award for antarctica i
feel like that would be a fair trade
happy birthday to marzia that was so
nice i like how this showed up before my
birthday which was yesterday today i'm
explaining racism to my dog
edgar
a.m
did you know basic
she feels
funny
no
you did not take them my legs
you're completely fine who said that
why can't i feel my legs
prior to the operation
operation
oh bright edgar
[Laughter]
hello felix
hell yeah
in the flesh
and some of yours too
why
why
think feel it
legs
such a clear silence true true that i
can never accomplish anything with my
short stubby legs
i'm a cat animations huge huge people
you love that yo go sub avocado
animations wow that's amazing sub i want
to own antarctica ready to do your thing
so we're still working out the details
it will happen eventually trust me in
the ceiling shut up felix you're going
in the [ __ ] ceiling 2017 with
something else
what is this journalist doctor youtuber
make your choice what will you be it's
official
let's go we just need an anthem pro army
nine year old nine year old or 19 year
old anti-norway antarctica nation height
time oh god damn it yeah you got me
there bro if anyone sports that haircut
on the left now you'd be like what the
hell are you doing yo
got that dripping a thousand one hundred
years ago based mummy my girlfriend said
you guys would like this i'm not sure
why holy [ __ ]
that that chair has seen some days man
jesus the four horsemen of invisibility
beastmaster 64. he could be anywhere
right now that's a good halloween outfit
hey guys so i rewatched the animated
movie here in my country called hey up
ka and look what i found i can't believe
i missed dude i'd be curious to like
make a video trying to find all the time
pewdiepie is referencing like media it
seems like a fun video running i'm
writing that down that's cool thanks for
sending that felix in the past said that
if frogs will be added into minecraft he
would name one sleepy i remember that
yeah you guys have a tendency of
remembering things now when frogs will
come to minecraft let's remind him okay
thank you i will i will
i can't wait to see my pace again i kind
of miss it to be honest me and the boys
enjoying the cold one cheese hell yeah
cheese unironically no bias only true
spitting [ __ ] pewdiepie can flavor is too
good
it's too good tastes so much better than
any other energy drink that i had to
tell them to stop sending it to me
because it's so delicious and it's all
you ever want to drink when did you join
hmm
must have been 2012 or something you
know what i probably had a different
avatar before the 2012 and then i think
about it i can't believe i got away with
2017 though whoa
hell yeah took 50 seconds to make
damn
ballpoint pen drawing that's sick love
that i miss this kind of stuff with the
way very cool
hundred meal club
let's go
pewdiepie eating pizza there you go we
finally got to the controversy of me
eating pizza it's gotta be here
somewhere hey
yeah
i love that what language is this that
philippine a language damn bro y'all
speaking enchantment people right
oh that's so pretty i love this fanta i
drew marzia in that one clip where felix
shot so
nice felix with mighty fans felix
remembers your sims uh well accurate you
better watch out simps i talked to my
cat nine years ago from my house two
streets away from felix oh she's 19 damn
i was wondering if they ever met did my
cat ever poop in your garden feel like
serious question bro i cannot honestly
say i remember but that's a very cute
cat though i will say that
no
leave the rainbows alone
stop it you want you've gone too far
norway the war continues
it will never stop being funny and then
he took a sh in the shower funniest
thing i ever heard in my life
[Laughter]
bro 2018 or i don't know what year felix
can you confirm this is how you eat
pizza
yes yes that's how i eat pizza i will
now address the pizza controversy okay
i'm gonna explain to you why eating a
pizza with knife and fork like this is
the superior version of eating a pizza
okay number one you get a pizza that is
unsliced what do you do this is what you
see everyone doing oh gotta start
while you're doing this
i'm already enjoying a sweet savory
flavor of that
pizza in this perfect steak right while
you're cutting up your pizza i can start
eating number one more efficient okay
and as a sub category of that cold pizza
tastes bad so the more time that passes
the more you're wasting your pizza so
it's double efficient the way i eat the
pizza number two when you eat a meal and
you have all these different things on
the on a plate what do you eat first do
you eat the bad thing the things that
you don't like so much first or do you
eat the bits that you like first
obviously you eat the things that you
like first because of also what we said
before with efficiency it tastes good so
why would i waste my time eating the
worst part of the pizza
when i can eat the best part of the
pizza right away and if you think the
crust is the best part of pizza i'm
sorry i can't argue with you you're just
stupid number three people say it's a
waste to eat uh pizza without not eating
the crust i'm wasting food this is an
outdated mindset that people haven't
questioned themselves because they were
taught by their parents when they were
children to not waste food which is so
yes i understand but it's actually
proven to be unhealthy and that you will
not live as long if you overeat your
food okay these are facts then you know
once i've eaten the middle the most
delicious part in the most efficient way
possible and if i'm still hungry i can
dabble into the pizza crust if i if i so
please thank you
i would encourage everyone to try eating
a pizza like this because it is the most
superior way of eating a pizza there's
just no argument that works against it i
have yet to see any reason i rest my
case all right thank you for watching
another episode of friday repair pack
check out the merch we got oaky peepee
oh they sold out never mind don't check
out the merch we sold that apparently
show us what i know all right tough luck
guys do not subscribe to pewdiepie
highlights they will not take over me
and that's it see you guys tomorrow
brofist